[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here we are back with another empathy
chat what are we calling this Seth
the empathy hour even though this is
going to probably be 25 minutes
um we have an incredible guest who I
actually think exudes them but then
we'll go into that in a minute
um Christine Tosi is a incredible
creative Superstar and entrepreneur I'm
going to let her introduce herself and
we will do what we're doing on this show
which is taste the new empathy wines
talk about empathy uh in general and
shoot the [ __ ] in general over that so
Christina have you been
hi Garrett I've been all right you know
I I mean if you ask me because you know
me I'm like a stubborn Optimist at all
costs I've been really well despite
everything that's going on because I
think I I know this about me and I know
people like you are similar where when
you decide that that is your mindset
that's how you see everything the harder
the reality the more you lean into the
sort of like bold countries that's right
I I totally agree with you the darker it
gets the more practical optimistic I get
a hundred percent so it always feels
weird and guilty to be like I'm doing
really well but it's because when I
achieve that like you know that the
scales are tilting in a negative
Direction that's when I really lean into
like we need more goodness we need more
of a reminder that that there is this
that there is to to every Force there is
an opposing force and I think that's
people like you guys need to show up you
know these these are I mean I I I I I I
tell people like there were optimistic
people during World War II and during
the black plague and during you know
like that's I couldn't agree with you
more this concept that you're not
allowed to counter negativity with
bright positivity is actually remarkably
misunderstood yeah it's also easier for
me because I'm a pastry chef by trade
right like that's what I do for a living
that's what we do at Milk Bar I tell the
team you know like our job we our job is
to help people escape yeah 100 showing
up whether it's making a bad day good or
an amazing day you know marking a moment
in in the most amazing day in someone's
life and that I suppose that's probably
why I also chose chose the profession
for a living because there's something
about baked goods that do that without
without having to have the words because
a lot of times we don't ever feel like
we have the right words or we feel
guilty when we're saying the words or or
I mean that's part of empathy too right
like knowing how there's people where
they are and the easiest way to do it in
my mind is like show up with a platter
of cookies with the cake was sent it you
know like those baked goods do the work
and say the things that you can't always
figure out how to save
yeah donuts and croissants and muffins
have definitely said things to me
oh my God I love those things actually
Christine let's look why don't we take
two minutes tell everybody a little bit
about who you are for the people that
don't know reading the headline of this
podcast uh so Optimus
we should uh uh we ship uh treats uh
Nationwide we have uh these wonderful
bakeries from east coast to West Coast
and we're now in the aisles of the
grocery store and I'd say what we do I
call it a Porky American style Bakery
because we take risks on your Classics I
would never want to compete with
someone's with your croissant or your
donut right but I want to make an apple
cider donut cake that brings the spirit
of what that donut does your classic
first memory of a donut and sort of
twist it and turn it on its head in a
way that ideally also like breathes life
and possibility and reminds you of who
you are without challenging these really
sort of like spirited spiritual moments
uh and reminds you that every single day
and moment an opportunity is like to
bring a little bit more of you into it
um these really connective Dynamic
sticky ways how did that happen who
inspired you in baking life
I learned to bake tactically from the
matriarchs in my family mom Grandma's
aunts I saw what baked goods did in the
world
yeah they were our conduit out of the
house into the community to like an old
folks home someone that was sick what
have you
um
and then I guess from like an actual
like Mentor standpoint probably the
person that inspired me to turn things
on their head was like 10 year old me
when you're making like crazy
concoctions in the kitchen you're like I
think this tastes good and then the
person that probably validated it most
was Wiley Dufresne who had the time a
restaurant wd-50 on the Lower East Side
because that's what he was doing with
Savory food and then David Chang kind of
like gave me the push off the ledge from
Momofuku where I was helping him run
operations in the restaurant and it's
sort of like I think you're on to
something like he was all about loud
food attitude flavors
breaking rules through food on the
Savory side and he really sort of gave
me my first start so it's a mishmash of
people but you know it's a long and
Winding Road life is right it's it's all
connected and none of it's ever linear
speaking of my connected but not linear
Journey wine was such a big part of this
where does wine sit in your ecosystem
and have you drank wine are you into
wine do you like wine Ebbs and flows are
you so well first of all I'm enjoying
the excuse to have a glass of this
freaking delicious empathy rose with you
call it work that's always a joy you
know always a joy yes
um my toesie is actually cozy is
Northern Italian and so my family's all
from the Piedmont region of Italy and so
I was raised
um on this sound nebiola
naviolo barolo is definitely the wine of
choice in my household as such though
obviously
um nebulos barbarescos those those for
me those are my comp like if the the
croissant with the croissant and the
donut are for you
um a great bottle of red wine from the
Piedmont Region that that's touting uh
for me it's all like capital B barolo is
always my like favorite place to go and
that is my that's my comfort blanket but
I've had the fortune because of my
spouse to visit
um you know all different parts of the
world
um and to visit Wineries and I have
it it's quite interesting when you are
like deep enough into your whatever it
is that you do for a living with like
great Passion you start to connect into
other people who are doing absolutely
gone things and to go like holy smokes I
totally relate to that Jean Louis Shaw
was like my favorite Winery visit
because watching him
Blend Wines and walk like watching how
you know the grapes that grow on this
side of the Hermitage versus that side
of the Hermitage two totally different
things and I was like oh my gosh you
could be a pastry chef I would like to
think I could be a wine maker that could
a hundred percent that's all that's
dollars in a in a bottle of wine but
that that for me is what I what I go to
quickly when I think of wine in my life
what do you got well what I was going to
say was that really resonated for me
because I think growing you know when I
was 14 is when I started my education on
wine like you know Jean Louisa hit my
radar literally when I was 15 years old
reading Robert Parker's wine Advocate
that's probably the first time I saw
that name and so
going through that journey of being 15
let's say to 30 where obviously the
first five six years of that I didn't
really drink wine and then starting the
Journey of 21 to 30 and then 21 to 23
was very different than 23 to 30 because
21 to 23 was very concerning because
everything just tasted like red wine and
white wine right I was going to be this
big wine guy and I was like crap I don't
know what they are saying like when it
has what's Blackberry well I don't
understand like I don't taste chocolate
this is just red wine this isn't tasty
yeah like chocolate ice cream and then
right and then like khaki in New Zealand
sauvignon blanc really scared me I was
like wait do I have to drink caffeine uh
you know but you know you go through
that journey and then and then really
starting to get to really understand it
and then to your point that decade of
traveling around the wine world and
watching people and then the collectors
and it just really
kind of being in that place of 30 35
years old and just knowing an ungodly
amount and being deeply passionate about
it has really serviced me well in the
rest of my career whether it's the
details of how to do proper marketing or
nft land now or looking at artists talk
about their nfts
Collectibles like all the stuff back
here it's all been connected so what
what do you do you drink Rose or is that
not something you drink
no no no I find that the one thing
that's consistent for me is having a
like wonderful glass of red wine that
like soothes the soul after a long day I
find my drinking are you a one glass of
red wine in a day gal
I am I am I'm not like I might like I
won't go
unless I'm dining out and it's a real
occasion it's like one glass I I could
never eat just one donut or one
croissant I am that's not my personality
but there's something really soothing
about looking forward to a glass of
really great red wine at night uh and
drinking it slowly and really savoring
it it's quite hilarious because it's not
how I would be the house and do you kind
of drink the same bottle for like three
days and then move on is that kind of
how it works giving it easy
my my counterpart will vary happily help
drink the other four glasses yeah so
exactly exactly so you're set yeah yeah
so it's a it's a new you start together
and then it's finished off I love that
like this Rose is is at its perfect time
because we're like on the brink of
spring and it's reminding me like just
like you see things start to come out of
the ground their butt on the branch
you're like oh heck yeah it's almost you
know what I mean like it's almost time
for the moment we're craving other types
of wine different temperatures and so on
and drinking occasions like for me that
glass of red wine is very spiritual for
me alone but but I think of all of the
other Libations like I mark them in how
I live my life at different times of
year based on what I'm craving or what
I'm eating with or the kind of company
I'm enjoying what do you like just
personally though you know again I'm
worried on this show people try to make
me feel good I didn't make this wine we
have an incredible wine maker so if you
hate it I'm equally just as happy
um what what stands out for you in the
Rose like what what do you like like the
crispness the flavor profile what stands
out
what I like about it is
um it is
not it's not too dry and it's not too
sweet and so there's something about it
that's rose-like but it's also I like a
really good um Albarino like that's
probably my summertime spring summer
that's another thing that I love to
drink in the backyard and there's
something about it that that starts to
sort of make me go mentally based on its
flavors in that direction but what I
like about it is it's not to
um it's not too intense One Direction or
another yeah which I really appreciate
it's funny I had it the other day and I
am such a big
white wine fan are you really massive I
think white wine is incredibly
underrated because people think you
graduate to Reds yeah interesting at
four o'clock in the morning you know
Wiley Wiley did you know Wiley when he
was dating Liz Willette
no no I started working with them just
after that got it so like you know I
really grew up in the wine business and
like was in Jersey but the whole New
York wine scene and when I would come
here and nerd out with the Psalms where
people in the wine business like Liz why
at least former girlfriend or while you
know like when I was I remember when
wd-50 opened like I was there like week
one
um uh you know I I really
was taken aback in my youth in my early
20s mid-20s that the most serious wine
sommeliers were drinking white wine at
night it's like spotted pig in its
Heyday in the 2000s when that whole
restaurant scene in saliers were hanging
out there like two three four in the
morning
you know I didn't do that often because
I was just kind of always working retail
but a couple of times I found myself
there
the summer Gates were drinking Riesling
and it really struck me early on and I
got very formed by the wine leaders of
the New York wine scene back then and
and really when you love and this will
make sense to you when you love
something deeply
you're 360 about it you're not where
everyone else is and and so yeah I'm a
huge white wine fan and the rose on
empathy always tries to strive to over
deliver for high acid white wine
drinkers and that's why I think so
interesting it's if that's the intention
for me it's like spot on yeah
I'm gonna open the rose because I'm
curious I like to go to the thing that
I'm like I don't think I'm going to be
drawn to this as much and then that for
me is always where I go first because
I'm that's where I'm the most curious
that's really interesting
let's talk about empathy before we get
out of here as a kid growing up how did
that word now that you understand that
word play and then more not more
importantly but equally important
because there's so many entrepreneurs
how do you think about empathy as a
leader of your businesses
I think it's a kid my
mom always raised us to
do the thing that other people weren't
doing which is to say if there was like
a kid on like recess that didn't have
anyone to talk to it was like you go to
that person right like you show up for
the people that don't seem like they
have someone that's showing up for them
in the way that you might and that has
oh that had always been the way that we
were raised she also hilariously enough
she's an accountant she's the most
passionate accountant you've ever met I
know her clients that she's had her
entire profession I know them because
she's the account that's like when I
show up with your taxes I'm also going
to show up with like a bag of chocolate
chip cookies or when it's your X or Y or
Z or when you're having a hard time in
this place or that place we would go
over to her clients homes and like bring
our toys or our baby dolls or our
puzzles or what have you because she was
just like when you are going to show up
for someone you show up for them it you
meet them in their moment and in their
place and when I think about it from
uh from building a business standpoint
obviously got to choose a great got to
choose a great um thing that we are
showing up in the world through baked
goods that does so much of that natural
empathetic work but also as a leader
especially in the last two or three
years right like you could never
underestimate the power of not making
assumptions and really asking someone
how you doing how you feeling following
up with them on something that they
shared with you digging into what is
below the surface and also like just
asking yourself like do I feel like I'm
getting all of this person do they seem
distracted do they seem super happy what
is that about you know and trying to
understand like what is below the
surface of someone and then showing up
for them there because oftentimes at
least when you're the boss right people
are showing up for you and they're
following your lead and they're taking
your lead you both want them to be seen
and you want them to also understand by
your empathetic leadership how to show
up for their team and leverage people's
super powers to the utmost acceptable
because it's going to make them feel
great and too because it's going to
serve your business best
what was the toughest transition from
going from like a senior executive in
someone else's company to being the last
line of defense and being the queen bee
in your own
such a great question
people anticipate the fact that you'd
have to always be on
like actually like that didn't that that
for me was the like that was where I was
gonna go but I was like well no actually
because how I did I live by the like how
you do everything is everything and so
when I was working for someone else I
was already doing that they would be
like you're already acting as if it was
yeah got it you were I think
going home it's more about the thing
that I always warn my friends and when I
say warn I just really want them to be
prepared is even if you're the number
two or the number three in a company
the fact that on Saturday evening you
have to be mentally prepared that
there's a leak in the building
there's a level of never being off kind
of similar to
being a parent like I'm watching 86 year
olds for free like some of my favorite
conversations that I stumble on I have
this combo with this person I'm playing
six months ago she was so worried about
her 67 year old son as if he was four
and I remember walking away from that
thinking this is what I've always
thought about business it's like you'll
you know once a parent always a parent
when they're when you know there's a
great Russian saying that says
little kids don't let you sleep big kids
don't let you live and and it really
just translates they're like you're
always a parent right you're always a
parent and and that's how I think what
happens when you start your own business
you don't actually get to breathe and
when you're the number six or the number
13 when you go on vacation you are
checked out when I'm on vacation I'm
anxious that I'm about to get a photo
about the [ __ ] up my vacation yeah my
husband's like why are we even at the
beach you don't even want to be here
like your brain is back by the way to
that point that's why I've really fallen
in love with the last two weeks of
August Thanksgiving week Christmas week
because the collective World kind of
looks at each other and says we're
checked out yeah New Year's Day that
week last week
business best no one's trying to buy
dessert that week Noah's trying to hit
you up everyone's done with dessert for
a week and you're just like okay you
know the literally from Christmas to
like January 7th I am at my mom
that was for those two weeks um
talk to me before we get out of here on
what you're excited about just a little
five minutes of Christina life like like
what are you most excited about your
businesses or in popular culture
anything on your own that's funny yeah I
mean my my thing right now so I just
finished writing this book it's out in
the world it's called dessert can save
the world and it is
I guess technically from a book
publisher standpoint it's a memoir but
really for me it's it's a remind it's
it's all the things that make me who I
am that make me like ferociously hungry
curious
um never always having the feeling never
being satisfied with like we need more
individual individuality we need more
people being themselves and showing up
for themselves in the world I do that
through dessert but like that could be
it could be wine could save the world
because everybody could save the world
any of those things right and for me I'm
just excited about
sharing that with more people and
watching them figure out what that maybe
it's dessert for them too I don't know
and just figuring out how to do more of
that because
I uh
it's it's the it is acknowledging that
like we are in a bliss we will always be
in a blissful Ballot or or lack thereof
Balancing Act of life and we're all
trying to figure out how to survive and
how to make the most of it and how to
thrive and how to learn as we go and for
me I'm like I'm excited to show up for
you every day I'm a lifetime learner and
I'm I'm just excited about what that
book brought out of me sharing it with
more people and just doing more of the
work on the clock and off the clock
right like even having written it and
talking about it I'm like oh my God
there's an opportunity I could help I
could help this person do this from X Y
and Z but I'm the most excited about
those things knowing that this audience
that's listening has a lot of aspiring
authors and currently people in their
book deal writing books what was what
was you've done books before though
right cookbooks mostly this is the first
non-cook book right written what did you
learn in this process from a commercial
standpoint so not the writing process
but of how many you want to sell whether
it did more or less or how or what lists
you wanted to make or what the publisher
did or didn't do like real talk before
we get out of here yeah
I think they're a Publishing House knows
a lot right and so it's important to use
and leverage them as a partner but it's
important to remember and by the way
this goes in leading your business and
and no one knows better than you do and
that's not to say you know everything
you have to come down to earth and say I
don't know everything I need great
partners that are experts in this field
but they don't know the heartbeat of
these Pages the way that you do so
they're going to Market it the way that
they know a book that looks a little bit
like this it's the size and the shape
they know how to make the wheel turn but
you know how to amplify it you know
who's going to read it you know who you
wrote it for you know what it means you
know how it's going to deliver and you
have to challenge them you have to
challenge yourself to say these people
know how to sell books but you have to
challenge yourself to say how can I make
this better am I asking the right
questions how do I challenge this
assumption or that assumption whether
it's volume or are you trying to make
New York Times bestseller how do you do
that they're going to give you the
Playbook that works for all their offers
within this within this range but you
have to figure out yeah
to be even less politically correct just
for everybody's listening there's not a
publisher on Earth that knows how to
sell one book
it's not what they do what they do is
they run a business which is a great
business of finding talented people who
are capable running books
printing those books getting those books
to the stores but let there be no
confusion the most obvious mistake that
I see from all my friends and aspiring
authors is that there's a proper
assumption that your publisher is going
to be a sales engine and it is not true
yeah it's just not it's very clear to me
I've got a lot of them in the world I've
got a lot of friends with them and
that's not a Razz to Publishers and it's
not a rap it's just the way it actually
is and I think your point is really well
taken yeah and if you want to be their
number one office sir it's because you
do all of the legwork right like they're
otherwise they're gonna treat you like
all of their other officers which is
you're one of many authors and this is
my job and so I show up and I'm gonna do
this and I'm gonna give you the same you
know book of tactics but you are the
person that has to go out and do the
work and prove it out because you're not
going to get into it you're not going to
get anyone's time or attention otherwise
but also great news you're the one that
wrote it so you know the subject matter
you know why you think it should exist
you know what drove you to it and you
just have to go out and hustle do the
works it's always that's a that's a
really good way to end this I'm going to
leave it at that Christina thank you so
much for being on the show
great to see you again